cette jeune française qui se promènent à
manhattan n'a rien d'une touriste élise
et guides touristiques et aujourd'hui
elle d'accompagner une famille à
brooklyn
en chemin elle va retrouver par hasard
henri mari et leurs quatre enfants
[Musique]
dans
elise va faire découvrir brooklyn à
cette famille pour moi c'est une ville à
part entière c'est hyper différent de
manhattan il ya une ambiance différente
et justement c'est pour ça que moi
j'adore emmener les gens et jean
brooklyn parce que de par l'imaginaire
l'image qu'ils en ont ils vont découvrir
quelque chose et ça donnait pas du tout
avoir mais henry qui vient de marseille
ne se soit pas complètement rassuré moi
qui suis marseillais
ça veut dire qu'on y va face sereinement
il ya 20 ans on n'allait pas marseille
sereinement bas aujourd'hui on y va ce
mandat je pense que brooklyn c'est
pareil à dents dans l'inconscient des
gens c'est pas la promenade qu'on peut
faire le soir faible 2 heures une sirène
[Musique]
des graffitis l'accueil n'est pas des
plus rassurants pour cette première
étape dans le quartier de bushwick vous
suit dans les années 90 c'était
criminalité ce quartier autrefois mal
famés du nord de brooklyn est très
réputé aujourd'hui pour son street art
l'art de la rue vous travaillé dessus
depuis combien de temps je commence tout
juste
et ça va prendre combien de temps
probablement la journée pour une journée
et là on fait ne sais pas c'est un
artiste car il est qui va se rejeter par
la police en l'occurrence à ce pas du
tout du vandalisme et personne à qui
appartient où l'entreprise à qui
appartient la porte a donné son accord
pour égayer
il ferme les magnifiques la tête je peux
vous demander votre nom mon nom
d'artiste
oui votre nom d'artiste l'amour suprême
la môme suprême
waouh c'est français une heure de visite
et un dépaysement assuré pour cette
famille sauf évidemment si en plus il
est hyper colorés les fresques
s'enchaînent les photos souvenirs
également assez d'azur fernandez qui
vient du chili a levé les jours des
choses très très colorés des personnages
comme ça beaucoup comme tout bon guide
touristique et 10 à ses notes pour
chaque artiste
mais la jeune française n'est pas la
seule à faire découvrir brooklyn au
détour d'une oeuvre notre famille
marseillaise a croisé un autre groupe de
touristes passer sa marque de fabrique à
la pythie fort generali fait un pda
c'est parti de new york n'est peut-être
plus si hors des sentiers battus que
cela les guides touristiques non j'en
vois jamais l'acea prévoit que j'en
croise pour cette visite de brooklyn
henry et sa famille ont déboursé 275
euros
ce tourisme alternatif est peu à peu
devenu un business
[Musique]
pour beaucoup new york c'est avant tout
manhattan des gratte ciel à perte de vue
une circulation infernale et des
trottoirs noire de monde
mais de l'autre côté de la rivière et du
célèbre pont de brooklyn
il y à tout autre chose c'est ici que
sont nés le rappeur jay-z la légende du
basket michael jordan ou celles de la
mafia
al capone
ces dernières années l'arrondissement de
brooklyn à tire justement toute
l'attention et rendrait manhattan
presque ringard
[Musique]
nouvelle énergie à brooklyn et j'avais
envie de faire partie de ce nouveau
mouvement brooklyn deux millions six
cent mille habitants fait presque deux
fois la taille de paris
et l'on y célèbre la diversité comme le
thé noir juive russe hispanique
il y a même depuis quelques années un
quartier français des expatriés qui ont
choisi ce morceau de new york pour ses
loyers moins élevés qu'à manhattan sa
faible densité et son calme si c'est un
vrai parc
tu vois aucune construction tu vois
aucun bulle des baux clean c'est un 180
kilomètres carrés avec terrasse vue
imprenable sur manhattan en est au
centre du monde magique new york compte
un peu plus de 50000 français et onze
mille d'entre eux ont choisi brooklyn
[Musique]
seconde partie de visite pour notre
famille marseillaise c'est le clou du
spectacle le quartier de williamsburg et
ses habitants un peu particulier
williams beurre surtout depuis way 12 15
ans il ya une population qui est arrivé
juste après aller les artistes le petit
ami les hipsters
est-ce que ça parle à quelqu'un ouais
c'est un peu caricatural à dire qu'ils
sont pas tous habillés avec les tenues
du jour
mais c'est quand même un style
vestimentaire particulier oui c'est une
sorte de bobos des bobos américain mais
un bobo un peu geek un bobo un peu geek
l'exposé un brin réducteur là venez ses
seins par ici
il va s'étoffer avec cette nouvelle
étape essentielle dans le quotidien des
boucles ynwa le coffee shop le café pays
pacifique de cet endroit typique de
brooklyn et toulouse dub c'est que la
voix il faut leur propre café ont cédé
hyper bon café et puisque très à la mode
c'est de montrer aussi qu'on le fait
justement sur place pour monter des
produits locaux cp non de leur côté les
filles ont inventé un jeu celui de
déceler les hipsters vous en conter
comment les stars voilà quelques-uns
c'est de la bonne êtes abonné au site
[Musique]
immeuble à taille humaine friperie chic
disque rg en boucle in et son atmosphère
décontractée conquiert peu à peu le
coeur de cette famille on donne envie
d'habiter très bien l'ambiance des
petites maisons ou plein de boutiques
sympa plein de resto sympa d'habiter là
pari gagné pour élise ce groupe de
marseillais a changé d'avis sur brooklyn
je pense que si un jour j'ai été muté à
new york
j'irais plutôt vers brooking que vers
manhattan regardez moi une photo avec
les gratte ciel de manhattan en
arrière-plan
pour cette famille c'est un souvenir de
vacances pour des milliers de français
installés ici à brooklyn
cette carte postale fait partie du
quotidien
poser ses valises à brooklyn emménagé en
famille dans une maison de ville aux
briques rouges une qualité de vie très
recherchée mais qui désormais a pris
jusqu'à près de 3 millions d'euros dans
certains quartiers voire plus beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup plus 30 millions
d'euros pour ce triplex de 1000 mètres
carrés
[Musique]
arrivé en 1997 à new york
cela fait quatre ans que patricia la
ligue en a quitté manhattan pour
brooklyn
cette française de 50 ans est agent
immobilier
ce matin elle a rendez vous avec l'une
de ses clientes qui est aussi une
connaissance du parc
[Musique]
ah je te vois ça va bien super super
donc que tout le monde
sylvie elles aussi françaises cherchent
à acheter un petit immeuble pour y
habiter avec sa famille et en louer une
partie
les deux amis se rendent d'abord dans un
quartier très en vogue à 20 minutes en
taxi
la maison a juste là classé monument
historique avril 2016 elle commence par
un immeuble de deux étages
la famille pourrait s'installer par
exemple dans un duplex au premier il ya
une très très belle lumière et j'aime le
fait que l'espace soit complètement
ouvert comme ça il ya encore tous les
détails originaux
là les shooters c'est tout à fait mon
type d' espaces en fait j'aime bien
qu'on s'est ouvert j'aime bien que les
chambres soient séparés sur un autre
étage et
moi j'aime bien ça pour une famille je
trouve sa pratique parce qu'on voit on
peut cuisiner on peut voir les enfants
plus tu peux mettre un ton petit coin
bureau là pour bosser c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de lumière 250 m² 1 million 600
mille euros un prix très raisonnable
pour new york
car en moyenne il faut compter 6400
euros le mètre carré à brooklyn contre
12500 euros
juste en face à manhattan je trouve que
c'est une super affaire
ouais je suis je suis vraiment surprise
que ce soit encore dispo et à mon avis
ce sera pas disponible longtemps à ce
prix là c'est une aubaine c'est une
aubaine donc les gens viennent ils sont
très curieux parce qu'elle est rénovée
elle est très bien placé il ya le métro
a juste à côté pour des gens qui en
travail sur manhattan cci nobel maxime
26 ans est un jeune dirigeant de start
up
il travaille à manhattan et vit à
brooklyn mais comme beaucoup avant de
pouvoir un jour acheté une maison il
s'est orienté vers la location ou plutôt
la colocation le jeune français
partagent cet appartement avec deux
colocataires un russe et une espagnole
qui fait la cuisine tu prépares un
gâteau non je fais des cookies ah ok je
sais pas comment fonctionne le four je
ne l'utilisent jamais
non on n'est qu'au lac ici depuis un an
et demi qu'on sait toujours pas comment
le four fonctionne c'est assez
représentatif du nombre de fois où en
cuisine ici ils sont déjà prêts j'ai
juste à les mettre au four ouais ouais
ouais c'est ça à brooklyn
ces jeunes ne prennent pas vraiment le
temps de cuisiner non pas vraiment ouais
c'est des cookies précuits quoi la
malbouffe n'a pas de quoi donner le mal
du pays à maxime qui est arrivé aux
etats-unis il ya cinq ans pas de
nostalgie non plus vis-à-vis de
l'immobilier à paris
maxime psr 850 euros par mois pour sa
chambre mais trouver un logement
brooklyn lui paraît tout de même plus
simple le marché beaucoup plus fluide en
fait si tu arrives et que tu mets les
deux mois de caution en tout cas en sous
location en location à jour ôta de payer
tu es viré mais tant que tu es ici et
que tu payes tu trouve beaucoup plus
facilement sauf qu'à paris c'est devenu
pour moi c'est un des trucs qui me
terrorise quand je rentre c'est de
devoir retrouver un appart avec la
complexité que c'est devenu quoi
[Musique]
on retrouve patricia et sylvie pour la
troisième et dernière visite de la
matinée cette maison en briques de deux
étages 250 m² dispose à l'arrière d'un
petit jardin privatif avec un peu
d'entretien sylvie et sa famille
pourraient avoir leur jardin eux
il veut plus la vendre à 2,4 il veut de
4,5 soit 8500 euros le mètre carré pour
une demeure pourtant loin d'être idéales
le chai de plongée voilà ça descend ou
les fenêtres c'est pareil que des
échanges et à changer plus après il ya
des choses qu'il faut inchangés comme tu
vois le
le toit sylvie est sceptique
le montant des travaux va la refroidir
encore un peu plus je pense au moins
cent cinquante mille peut-être plus 150
milles par étage non j rend tous n'ont
cessé c'est plus que ça c'est le double
en fait c'est c'est le double en général
c'est 80 mille dollars par étage pour
avoir quelque chose standards comme
rénovation les gens ont investi deux
millions cinq dans une maison à refaire
parce qu'ils ont trois enfants pour les
ja l'école qui à dix minutes à pied et
ça ça n'a pas de prix car cette école ce
n'est pas n'importe laquelle
c'est une des raisons majeures pour
lesquelles ces expatriés français
choisissent brooklyn
lundi matin il est presque huit heures
et les trottoirs grouille de parents et
d'enfants
ils se rendent à ps 58 l'une des écoles
élémentaires de ce district signe
particulier cet établissement public le
premier à avoir ouvert des classes
bilingues français-anglais suivi par
autant d'enfants de familles françaises
que d'anglophones de naissance parmi les
initiateurs de ces classes fabrice
jaumont 43 ans en charge de l'éducation
à l'ambassade de france
[Musique]
étonnant mais bien réel
beau clean speak french avec la
directrice adjointe
fabrice est venu faire un état des lieux
un mois après la rentrée m'aider
[Musique]
processus dans quatre mois
mieux vaut apprendre à lire dans les
deux mois je suis américaine
oui j'ai appris pour faire l'école et
puis j'ai passé du temps en france et
j'ai travaillé pour les compagnies
françaises et je suis très content
maintenant d'enseignants français avec
les petits français les petits
américains
ces enfants américains de grande section
de maternelle vont progresser en
français grâce aux cours mais aussi
grâce aux contacts de leurs camarades
francophones vous aimer apprendre le
français
[Musique]
tu parle un peu le français
qu'est ce que tu peux dire aux français
lancé en 2007 ce programme s'est étendu
depuis à 11 autres établissements de la
ville dont six à brooklyn sur les mille
enfants de l'école 150 sont issus de
familles françaises c'est dix fois plus
qu'il ya huit ans
ketty la directrice constate une
influence française grandissante dans le
quartier on entend parler français dans
la rue oui absolument
les études montrent que les élèves qui
apprennent deux langues renforcer leurs
facultés d'apprentissage mais aussi leur
capacité à résoudre les problèmes en
plus les enfants enseigne la langue à
leurs familles et aux adultes ici là
donc c'est une excellente expérience
pour est une très bonne expérience que
fabrice applique aussi à ses propres
enfants
j'en arrive à leur tour dans son
quartier c'est l'heure des devoirs pour
sa fille clés à 6 ans la fille de
fabrice et nathalie est elle-même
scolarisés en classe bilingue son niveau
first gold l'équivalent du cp
complètement balle je pense qu'elle est
parfaitement bilingue elle va devenir
parfaitement bill et rick et je pense
aussi parfaitement biculturel donc je
pense que ça c'est quelque chose que
j'aurais bien aimé revoir quand j'étais
gamin c'est une super choses même s'il
n'a pas grandi en parlant de langues
fabrice le valenciennois a tout de même
parcouru un sacré chemin
il lui suffit pour s'en rappeler de
monter sur son rouge stop le toit de son
immeuble
là on est au centre du monde et là c'est
des moments magiques
moi ça me fait toujours un effet surtout
quand il ya sept ans tu es les lumières
qui commence à s'allumer un nouvel tour
qui est là bas
liberty towers à la place des tours
jumelles c'est à savoir le reste de
fierté d'une ville qui s'est relevé quoi
ça c'est très important très important
l'une des chances des habitants de
brooklyn c'est que ce sont eux qui ont
la meilleure vue sur le skyline de
manhattan
un panorama unique sur le new york qui
ne dort jamais mais aujourd'hui les
jeunes loups sont à brooklyn
[Musique]
des milliers de jeunes entrepreneurs qui
ont fait le pari de réussir et de vivre
ici comme cette jeune créatrice de mode
qui s'est installée dans ce quartier
industriel de brooklyn reconvertie en
atelier mode elin a lancé sa ligne de
vêtements au début de l'année dans ses
bureaux qu'elle partage avec d'autres
sociétés
elle travaille sur ses prochaines pièces
c'est la collection était 2016 avec la
toujours des modèles en popeline blanche
je pars toujours du blanc et maintenant
par saison je rajoute une ou deux
couleurs dans le flot de la mode
contemporaine ses chemises haut de gamme
ont réussi à se distinguer le côté
arrondi avec le devant plus court le dos
plus long le fait qu'il ya une ouverture
en gouttes
c'est d'ailleurs ce modèle vendu 300
euros
bonjour je suis scarlett johansson qui a
permis un mode de se faire un nom il ya
six mois
l'actrice scarlett johansson porte la
chemise de mode et line lors d'une
émission culte regardée par des millions
de téléspectateurs
mais c'est pas possible c'est quelqu'un
d'autre une copié j'en sais rien et en
fait j'ai bien dû admettre que c'était
c'était bien mon chemisier
un coup pub qui a dopé les ventes de
cette marque conçu à brooklyn
fabriqué à manhattan cherché
l'inspiration décidé les croquis gérer
la vente en ligne et choisir des
matériaux mode est une créatrice
débordés j'ai reçu une commande modèle
en m parra longs gants m qui est un
modèle hiver donc du coup en général je
regarde si les biens pillés je vérifie
tout pour être sûr que que l'envoi est
bien car dans cette micro entreprise
c'est aussi mode qui se charge de
préparer les colis
la jeune femme promène encore le temps
de glisser un mot manuscrit pour chaque
cliente
madame hélène merci beaucoup pour votre
commande
j'espère que vous allez apprécier
apportez votre nouvelle chemise je pense
que c'est toujours important de
personnaliser tout ce qu'on fait une
attention que maud ne pourra peut-être
plus se permettre très longtemps car ces
créations sont de plus en plus distribué
dans quelques jours elle va justement
présenter sa nouvelle collection dans
une chaîne de magasins de luxe à
manhattan
[Musique]
ce n'est pas l'image la plus connue de
new york une plage à moins d'une heure
de métro des gratte-ciel le quartier de
coney island dans le sud de brooklyn et
son gigantesque parc d'attractions
attire autant les touristes que les new
yorkais
[Musique]
laura moreno s'y rend dès qu'elle le
peut l'année dernière c'est le
photographe de 29 ans a tout quitté sa
famille ses amis et marseille pour
s'installer à brooklyn
ici elle a trouvé son inspiration de
photographes
loin de l'agitation de manhattan
[Musique]
on n'a eu qu'à beaucoup de vent on voit
le sable qui bouge et j'essaie de voir
si je peux capturer ça avec mon appareil
photo
à l'inversé du cefac du ce qu elle a
choisi de se poser à brooklyn presque
sur un coup de tête après une semaine de
vacances passées ici
pour elle la ville à tous les avantages
de new york
sans ses inconvénients
beaucoup c'est un quartier beaucoup plus
sympa c'est qu'on sent plusieurs c'est
ça la mélanger à s'évader prendre l'air
du large
laura le fait régulièrement avec oscar
son mari un américain qu'elle a
rencontrés ici
l'ambition de cette jeune artiste
devenir un photographe de renom pour
réaliser son rêve américain
laure a dû trouver un petit boulot
[Musique]
chaque matin elle commence sa journée 17
heures sur la célèbre belfort d'avenir
ici les usines désaffectées se sont
transformés en des lieux branchés les
vieilles échoppes en des boutiques
sophistiqués comme cette pâtisserie
française où laura travail sept heures
par jour
sophie la patronne est française elle
aussi et pour laura elle est un peu plus
que son employeur
ce que sophie qu'à la boutique est très
tout ce qu'on veut dire qu'on est amis
et et j'ai aussi rencontré oscar ici et
on s'est mariés bonjour
tu peux avoir un muffin banane chocolat
ou à emporter
oui s'il vous plaît ce n'est pas encore
tout à fait la vie dont elle rêve mais
ici tout le monde la soutient demain
elle organisera sa première exposition
photo la pâtisserie vin s'improviser
galerie d'art c'est aussi ça brooklyn
pour laura le rêve américain est pour
l'instant une vie de bohème elle est aux
oscars son mari ont aménagé dans un
quartier populaire de brooklyn
il loue ce garage aménagé en studio pour
1200 dollars par mois laura ne
changerait sa vie pour rien au monde
sauf peut-être pour quelques mètres
carrés supplémentaires
vous trouvez quelque chose qui vous
plaît les appartements il y en a qui
sont assez qui sont assez sympa donc là
par exemple celui que vous voyez c'est
quoi c'est un studio c'est juste une
pièce en fait donc c'est un peu du même
genre qui s'ils y con on a puisé
ménagers salle de bain donc s'il n'y a
pas de pièce à part mais ça peut être
sympa de choses comme ça aussi 1500
dollars c'est cher mais c'est cher mais
bon après c'est new york c'est un choix
d'être à new york et de payer 1500 $
pour un appartement plutôt d'être avant
g8 à marseille dans un dans un
appartement avec deux chambres d'un t3
pour 700 euros donc c'est vrai que c'est
totalement différent
j'ai même pas de dix vendues par an de
ma soeur qui est mort je peux lui dire
bah oui bien sûr tu peux dormir sur mon
divan pendant une semaine
c'est possible mais ça me revient comme
ça qu'ils faisaient boire quelque chose
le coup de coeur pour brooklyn mais
aussi pour oscar sans lui elle aurait dû
abandonner son rêve de pouvoir s'y
installer durablement
moi je suis arrivé en juin dernier
c'était ça nous a permis de rester
ensemble à new york
parce que si on s'était pas mariage
aurait dû repartir je peux plus rester
aux etats-unis dans tout ça qu'on a
essayé de se marier pour s en simple
ouais tout le monde dise ah oui mais
c'est vrai c'est rapide mais c'est ça
l'amour ça vous fait faire des trucs
très vite
new york là où tout est possible
brooklyn où tout semble réalisable si la
qualité de vie la création sont à
brooklyn le business reste pour
l'instant essentiellement à manhattan
[Musique]
c'est le jour j pour mode la jeune
créatrice aujourd'hui avec carla son
mari elle va présenter sa toute nouvelle
collection dans un magasin de luxe de
manhattan
allez
pendant que les cadres ajustent leurs
costumes
la jeune créatrice apporte les dernières
retouches à son intervention devant les
vendeurs
ça c'est important aussi de fête
alors que j'étais
hier avec des veines
18 stations plus tard changement de
décor les voilà dans l'upper east side
l'un des quartiers les plus chics de new
york avec sa légendaire madison avenue
c'est là que se trouve ben 10 le magasin
où elle se rend la jeune française a un
peu de retard mais elle a une excuse
toute trouvée
[Musique]
c'est ce qui s'appelle être fashion
abylight ça veut dire que tu es en
retard mais c'est la fashion ce
programme chez barneys mode et carl
passe par l'entrée du personnel et ils
se sentent presque comme chez eux aux
jeunes c'est john la responsable des
achats pour la mode féminine qui les
accueillent
ça fait plaisir de vous voir avec quels
mots de passe en revue les portants elle
veut s'assurer que ces créations sont
impeccablement présenter ça s'est
tellement jolie ce merci ça c'est la
nouvelle nouvelle il ya une version
manches courtes aussi au printemps
dernier les acheteurs de barneys ont eu
un coup de coeur pour les créations de
la styliste française
nous avons trouvé cela si rafraîchissant
et audacieux elle a fait d'un produit
simple et basique quelque chose de
vraiment intéressant
la réaction de notre équipe a été
instantané nous avons adoré
nous étions vraiment enthousiaste un
magasin de luxe de manhattan lui déroule
son tapis rouge
ironique pour une marque dont les
étiquettes sont siglés brooklyn
au début on l'a vraiment con
déconseillés parce que ça pouvait avoir
des connotations un peu hipster
mais je trouve qu'il ya une nouvelle
énergie à brooklyn d'artisanat qui voit
là de très haute qualité voire voire de
luxe et j'avais envie de faire partie de
ce nouveau mouvement le magasin ouvre
ses portes dans quelques minutes
les clients vont pouvoir découvrir la
toute nouvelle collection de la jeune
française et ses modèles même qui va
fournir des arguments de vente au
personnel bonjour tout le monde je suis
mode et voici mon mari carla pour moi il
n'y a pas mieux aux états unis que
d'être vendeuse chez par nice et c'est
le
le meilleur la meilleure boutique
que ce soit dans ce magasin de luxe ou
ailleurs à new york le brooklyn made in
france se vend très bien
si le succès de la mode française est
toujours une réalité le produit tendance
du moment c'est la langue française
manhattan un après-midi fin septembre
tout près de times square
la france tient salon des stands
consacrés comme souvent quand les états
unis pensent à la france à la
gastronomie
mais la star du jour n'a rien d'un chef
étoilé celui qui est sous les
projecteurs
c'est fabrice venu faire la promotion de
ces classes bilingues hockey
même l'auteur français à succès marc
levy venu sur le salon pour une dédicace
n'a d'yeux que pour fabrice
bonjour jean marc
salon merci gros mercière
bravo pour tout ce que vous faites et
j'ai raté pour la francophonie c'est
magnifique je suis vos aventures chaque
jour merci beaucoup
vous connaissez monsieur moment
je n'ai pas personnellement mais je le
connais de nom et les chicanes et son
travail et ce qu'ils feraient tout ce
qu'il avait pour les classes bilingues
aux etats unis c'est une star l'esquivé
très connu il y avait une vraie envie
chez beaucoup d'américains surtout new
yorkais d'américains de la côte est de
pouvoir accéder à cette langue
mais voilà donc les programmes que mais
monsieur jeumont en place sont des
programmes de
vraiment très important vous permettre
ça donc ça permet ça permet à la culture
française et à notre pays de rayonner à
ogier déjà qui va nous parler
bonjour
deux à trois fromages le rayonnement du
français a tout de même ses limites pour
réussir une photo cheese fonctionne
apparemment mieux que fromage faire
parler de soi rencontrer ceux qui
comptent pour cela manhattan est encore
indétrônable mais dès qu'il s'agit de
respirer de profiter autrement de new
york brooklyn s'impose ce soir maxime
retrouve martin un français qu'il a
rencontrés ici
les deux amis sont de sortie pour
commencer maxime et martin vont
expérimenter la cuisine dominicaine dans
ce petit restaurant
m
bonsoir vous auriez une table pour 3
pour toi
on
[Musique]
sinon comment allez vous ça va et vous
même ce que les deux amis mti si c'est
l'atmosphère décalé du restaurant
[Musique]
et
ici c'était un ancien garage aujourd'hui
c'est un restaurant mais tous les
aspects du gaj l'ancien l'ancien mur les
matériaux le zinc et tout a été gardé
c'est ce qui fait le charme de brooklyn
on n'est pas dans un quartier très
touristique au final et
du coup double quant à elle trouvé une
écoute pépites comme ça dans mon arme
par un lieu typique où maxime et martin
doivent d'ailleurs déchiffrer un menu
écrit en espagnol
la sangria houleux
boléro kendo laisser réduire
quentin le frère de martin les rejoint
pour la soirée côtes de porc et banane
plantain pour martin rit jaune et poulet
pour maxime des saveurs nouvelles pour
ses deux amis le charme des états unis
c'est aussi de devoir faire des calculs
savants lorsque arrive l'addition la
coutume à new york
et de rajouter environ 20% de pourboire
à sa note prenons
un verre enfin une bière ou deux plus un
pl
ballet
d à côté j'ai pas l'impression de penser
beaucoup moins jusqu ici là rien envie
de leur part d'autant que la soirée des
pas fini dans le même quartier
au bout de la rue ces trois français
poursuivent dans un bar où ce soir la
musique soul est à l'honneur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des prix raisonnables une ambiance
détendue ce lieu les change de tout ce
qu'ils connaissent en france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
dans me tomber dans des endroits comme
ça tu rentre immédiatement tu profites
rendu le vent était là pour profiter
panne et finalement faut que l'endroit
soit cool et photos landeron à soi il
est il bon maintien c'est le verbe aux
états unis qui veut dire que c'est
tranquille sans complexe et sans prise
de tête
setchine car évidemment les trois amis
ne sont pas seulement là pour boire
tranquillement des verts ils mettent
rapidement le grappin sur crédit et lisa
originaire de detroit vous savez combien
de temps que vous êtes ici moi ça fait
cinq ans cinq ans où j'ai commencé par
étudier à manhattan
[Rires]
ouais c'est vraiment le sentiment que
j'ai maintenant pas de sujet plus
fédérateur à brooklyn qu'un certain
dédain pour manhattan
ces tarifs de marché à times square et
de te dire comment si j'arrivais ici et
pourquoi je veux partir tout de suite
ouais c'est pénible times square
la soirée défilent les verres d'alcool
aussi les rencontres elles se font de
plus en plus incongrue vous allez
apporter des baguettes avec vous nous
avez apporté du vin s'il vous plaît j'en
ai besoin
j'en ai besoin maintenant j'ai tellement
fort je suis américain je n'ai rien j'ai
besoin d'une baguette et devint
maintenant pour pouvoir être à la
hauteur de la tradition d'hemingway s'il
vous plaît
maxime lui a décidé de rentrer tôt
[Musique]
avant de partir il fait à ses amis un
oeil à l'américaine une accolade que ces
expatriés ont déjà adopté pour laura
c'est le grand jour
au petit matin elle arrive à la
pâtisserie avant de prendre son service
la jeune photographe accroche les photos
de sa toute première exposition
l'accrochage terminée
laura enchaîne sur sa journée de travail
dans quelques heures
elle accueillera ses premiers invités
[Musique]
bonjour comment ça va merci d'être venue
enchanter j'essuie l'aura fait un tour
il y a des choses à boire et à manger
les amis proches et la famille sont
venus soutenir laura regarde oscar ta
soeur est là oui je suis un peu nerveux
je sais pas je suis pas très à l'aise
dans ce genre situation intimider l'aura
du mal à promouvoir son travail
mais au fil des heures la photographe se
prend au jeu des questions merci d'être
venus c'est ce que vous faites
oui se sont tous donné trop tôt vous ne
pouvez faire un tour
j'adore la culture française
ces superbes franchement j'adore c'est
comment chanter jeu pendant six mois on
est beaucoup de bons commentaires
quand on connaît mon travail c'est sympa
quand même parce qu'ils sont intéressés
pour acheter des photos on a obtenu
c'est selon lui d'entreprise
pour sa première expo laura a vendu deux
photos à 300 dollars pièce brooklyn et
peut-être pour la jeune française le
début de son rêve américain